hey guys I'm Ryan right let's agree hot
damn [ __ ] cyber we're gonna watch the
trailer today for a little game called
dying light the gameplay trailer came
out at Gamescom here we go guys I hear
this I remember the first trailer
software this looked pretty good mmm
and I want to see this one badly cuz
everyone's everyone's like going is out
of Dead Island right this I'm like why
can't I be both okay I don't know thing
about this so now that you said that I'm
really excited cool you thrilled to be a
part of this experience amen hey the 40
experience Brian ray Augustine says
content
ah scary this guy still alive Shh mmm
Oh interesting
awesome oh wow how neat oh my god you
just jump over the bees that's pretty
sick oh my god like Daniel the guts and
stuff this is crazy
Oh co-op nice I almost feel like you
have to have co-op these days yeah
occupied a school harder by despre my
mind basically do not be on the streets
at night
Oh guys got mad hops okay
hey it is a weird anchor you may oh my
god those are not regular zombies never
mean that's cool are those the same guys
who made it on - no no no really
nope I remember the dudes that did uh
Brooklyn I think yeah what kind of that
well the publisher is the same Rick at
Paris I look stupid you couldn't have a
part out so I don't look stupid Jesus
dad it's a legitimate question yeah yeah
the way you guys answer really no no oh
[ __ ] did you get that idea from just
because we got smarts you know these are
these are particular uh video games
sports you have the movie sports mmm
video that's what that's that's all I've
got man you gotta give it up one thing
fine fine babe you have the movie smarts
that's more yeah Ryan Gosling yeah as
far as this game goes it does look
pretty [ __ ] sweet whereas Dead Island
2 looks more like it just uh let's bash
and [ __ ] em up game this has that it
looks like there's actually more
strategy to it see I'm more excited for
dinner I went to than this one although
until looks like simple more pure fun
yeah this one looks like oh you gotta
take this one more serious yeah it's
definitely a completely different tone
yeah anyone this might look like you
could actually die yes yeah this one
like oh if I myself I'm gonna die
whereas dead Ivan's like well if I'm
messed up because I ran out of bullets
yeah can't remember if I've seen someone
play like a demo of this or not but I
know free running plate as you could
tell from the gameplay there from the
trailer like free running is gonna be
like a huge thing so for you Mirror's
Edge people that should be really fun I
don't know if it's to the extent of
mirrors edge but it's gonna have a
little bit I like how they're adding
yeah because they even added in a sunset
overdrive yes until only I can put it to
it to has a lot more free running and
scaling and all that sort of stuff so
yeah I can totally participate in this
conversation
it's crazy you got a Nintendo hand yeah
cuz I like I like games he does like
games really hit that's that's like they
say if you want to go to New York and
blend in buy it
I love
New York shirt Statue of Liberty hat
American flag and you'll blend right in
so to make people believe I am a true
gamer you're rockin a Nintendo had a
quick question
yeah did the guy at the gift shop tell
you that of course the guy gift shop
told me that well something I'm [ __ ]
asked alright you know what to be fair
to be fair I would get that hat - so
would tar [ __ ] alright guys different
you to the channel you can subscribe
here to the real rejects dan has a
gaming channel for that cyber channel
and alyssa has a channel where she does
things around a biblical proportion so
this would be crazy
we all have channels isn't that exciting
we're all youtubers in a community oh my
god how [ __ ] nuts and then the couch
started shaking and I was I got into it
I got relieved at first I go oh just
like my Wiggles you don't know what's
going on push out some people out the
same reviewer he said can i get a
shoutout please Zini reviewer he's him
and alyssa should probably date cuz they
say - you look crazy
oh yeah just exploded ah oh my get my
balls just exploded you know I mean
orgasm penis joke penis jokes cement and
everything hey hey I have very good
looking semen same reviewer I'm gonna
send you a sample are you [ __ ]
kidding me whoa what I'm gonna send him
assembly my semen are you [ __ ] king
if you drink from it you gain super
strength oh gosh I am going wrong
Alyssa's contemplating whether or not
she's gonna do it the other crazy just
got me more comfortable a talk about
your sexuality the movie fan 356 hey
Brian in the rejects if you give me a
shout-out I will sign my soul to you
shoutout to you movie fan 356 give me
your goddamn soul you [ __ ] every
shot no should talk to
not judge exactly just know you not
talking you until you give us a [ __ ]
soul comment down below that is your
digital signature we own your soul thank
you Nick window all I can say is you
guys are really awesome you just earned
yourself a sub please Nick the big dick
you're not a prick and you make me sick
when you shove down your big dick down
my throat there you go that's your
rhymin shoutout rhyming right welcome to
the channel my friend welcome to the
channel welcome the channel well trailer
reactions and dick jokes